all right my next guest
is the governor of west virginia now
offering his state what he calls an
opportunity beyond belief
republican governor who was once a
democrat jim justice is proposing a plan
to repeal personal income tax gradually
making all west virginians cash positive
so how does he plan to pay for it and
can he get the support to make it happen
joining us now governor jim justice
uh from west virginia governor uh you
were going you kind of swum against the
tide you said you want the 1.9 trillion
pass
it and in turn you want to give west
virginians a payback
well that's exactly right brian you know
at the end of the day you know we got to
we got to get to through these wickets
that senator manchin you know kind of
slipped into the bill
to 11th hour and we've got to get
through all that as far as
making sure that we're doing everything
exactly right because we're not going to
do anything
except that but at the end of the day
we're poised in our state to be able to
extinguish our state income tax and if
we can do that
it will set our state state on a pathway
to who knows where it'll be all good
stuff what do you mean joe manchin made
it tough for you
well i think you know everyone knows
that we slipped language in
at the end and it was probably driven
from the standpoint of my state of the
state address where i said
really and truly right now is our time
to get rid of our state income tax and
you know just political stuff and
everything you know i'm very respectful
of joe manchin and i want nothing
but good for him but at the same time
that was a blow to west virginia and
we've got to vet that and make sure that
we're okay
on accepting the stimulus money and if
we can't
if we can't if we can't if we can't go
forward we just don't go forward with
the income tax deal
wow that's unbelievable so there's
something in the 1.9 trillion that
prevents you
from cutting taxes in your state
unbelievable it was sneaky
and if they were set proud of it they
should have said it and joe manchin
should have stopped it
it's good to be lucky and i just got
lucky the wall street journal just
dropped the story
and my gov my guess is the perfect guest
why
do democrats hate west virginia and it's
the story of really your success how you
parried away when coal dropped
you came up with another industry when
things started getting tough
you came up with a way to get the
vaccine to your people and you got
everyone mobilized with the pandemic
and now you found a way to bring other
industries to west virginia
does it bother you the democrats hate
you
well i mean brian i hope and pray none
of us hate one another and we we're all
americans when it all comes down to it
but
no it doesn't it doesn't really bother
me at all because you know
i'm doing the right stuff for west
virginia we've got west virginia on a
good path now
and a lot of people are finding west
virginia to be the diamond in the rough
that they missed
rather than the kind of backward state
or the poor state or whatever it may be
you know but west virginia is really on
a move and we have
diversified our economies and we we have
absolutely led the way on the pandemic
from
from the standpoint of first on the
nursing homes to test them all
first to vaccinate them all getting the
vaccines instead of leaving them on
shelves in a warehouse and trying to
figure out
a system that i always say is just count
the egg sucking cows why count the legs
and divide by four
just count the cows and then and we
didn't want those vaccines on the
shelves
so we got him in somebody's arm and
really and truly we've saved a bunch of
lives in west virginia and uh
i think we're on a really good pathway
in west virginia well here's what
do you worry i don't know if you watch
the start of the show if not i'll get
you a copy
but i just talked about way the way
president biden really plans with the
next infrastructure package
to push the green new technology and
he's already banned drilling on federal
land are you where he's going to
cut into your fracking success and if he
starts doing that
are you going to take action against the
federal government
well brian i surely hope and pray he
doesn't do this
we would absolutely take the action and
i would i would just shoot this shot you
know across
the valve our president and say i wish
him the very
best but if you'll just step back he now
is in the hot seat
a lot of the criticism for president
president trump you know are coming home
to roost now
you know when it really boils right down
to it what's happening on the
on the texas border what's absolutely
happening
happened in texas when we all we had so
many people freezing to death
now what's happening with our our fossil
fuels and everything
and we're not we're going to awaken to a
situation
where everybody's going to realize we
can't do without fossil fuels today
maybe someday but we can't do without
that today and if we don't watch out
this president's going to run us right
dead off a cliff
yeah you better stop listening to aoc
and just for the record he was uh the
governor of west virginia not only can
get vaccines in people's arms
he would also tie a tie in 45 seconds uh
it was
about two minutes ago he had no tie on
and he suddenly realized he wanted to
have one
and you are a game day player governor
thanks uh congratulations on this
congratulations
on the column that's about to come out
it's actually a big compliment to you
on your staff and your state appreciate
it
brian thanks for all you do every day
you're a superstar we really appreciate
you
you got it thank you sir